so I know you have to be very careful
about spoilers I respect that uh in the
first season of Ahsoka of the episodes
that of of the first season which was
which is the episode that you're most
excited for fans to see
like one through eight or ten I don't
know how many episodes it is you know
the entire show
really a film
watching it um it's one story but I
would say actually episode
episode
six I think I won't I won't pressure you
so Dave wrote all the episodes this
season what surprised you about the
writing that maybe you didn't expect
think that
that has done
a brilliant job expanding
um our understanding of lightness and
dark in that spectrum and what comes
within it and um I just trust him and I
trust him wholeheartedly so um
I think
what I love about him is that he loves
silence and he loves speaking through
silence
um and that that is not surprising but
it's something that I definitely enjoy I
like learning about the behind the
scenes the making of a show what what
surprised you about making the series
that you didn't expect or what might
surprise audiences to learn about the
making of the series
um I would say that when you think of
Star Wars and the vastness of the world
itself it would be surprised to come to
set and see how
contained and small it is and how family
like we are it's all part of one
organism and um
yeah it's it's it feels like a family it
feels like a little village to be part
of so that would be surprising last
thing for you uh you obviously get to go
you're involved in action on the series
uh what can you tease about some of the
action you're involved with
rewards non-disclosure agreement but um
there's a lot of
fighting going on in the series that I
can promise you and the fights
are brilliant thanks to our fight
coordinator Ming
so I'm excited for you to watch it truly
on that note I'm just going to say I
cannot wait to see it thank you for your
time